un aumento de los casos que ha dejado a
muchos reorganizando el periodo navideño
aunque el gobierno británico no ha
introducido ninguna restricción formal
en las reuniones sociales y no es
recomendado cancelar las fiestas
navideñas su asesor médico en jefe
crisis güity sugirió que la gente
minimiza el contacto social bares y
restaurantes y otros locales que
esperaban que no se repitiera lo de las
pasadas navidades están informando
cancelaciones con cbs es una puñalada
constante en la espalda básicamente por
todas estas noticias y regulaciones en
estas semanas es cuando conseguimos
reservar cooperativas que nos dan algo
de dinero para pasar enero y febrero y
sin eso vamos a pasar muchos apuros en
los próximos meses algunos diputados del
partido del primer ministro boris
johnson acusaron al gobierno de imponer
un bloqueo por sorpresa el carmen es no
challenge y porque el gobierno no está
diciendo a la gente que cancele cosas no
está cerrando negocios pero lo que
decimos es que hay cosas fáciles y
eficaces que todos podemos hacer para
protegernos por ejemplo usar mascarillas
asegurar una buena ventilación y lo más
importante ahora mismo ir a vacunarse
porque es la mejor protección que
tenemos
en los últimos días se han visto largas
colas en los centros de vacunación de
londres y otras ciudades mientras el
público sigue el consejo del gobierno y
los funcionarios de salud aumentan sus
esfuerzos el miércoles administraron
casi 750.000 dosis un récord diario de
vacunaciones la semana pasada down in
suit actualizó sus directrices para
aconsejar a la gente que trabaje desde
casa si es posible y ordenó el uso de
mascarillas en algunos lugares así como
pases sanitarios para ingresar a sitios
particulares los ciudadanos británicos
que se encuentran fuera del reino unido-
y las personas que quieran viajar aquí
también se enfrentarán a un período de
vacaciones incierto después de que el
gobierno francés introdujera nuevas y
estrictas medidas de viaje este jueves
parís prohíbe los traslados no
esenciales hacia y desde el reino unido
a partir del sábado